Here we describe the general process
of splicing and demonstrate how an open
reading frame is maintained within the mature
messenger RNA, or mRNA. In eukaryotes, mRNA is
transcribed from the five prime to three prime
direction using one strand of DNA as template.
As the RNA is generated, it is processed
in order to give rise to a mature message.
One key step of RNA processing is splicing. We
can use English letters, words, and sentences
to illustrate the key concepts of splicing. Let
us imagine that the following precursor message
has been generated. Let us also pretend that
each letter of this transcript is a nucleotide.
As written, this message does not make much sense.
But if we highlight the exons using red letters, we can identify a
short sentence when we read just
those letters. Conveniently for this illustration,
all the exons are short, but do keep in mind
that exons and introns are of variable lengths.
In real life, the minimal size for an intron is
about 40 nucleotides. Since the processed message is
a complete English sentence, the first six letters
of the precursor message highlighted in blue
before the definite article "the" corresponds to
the five prime Untranslated Region, or 5' UTR.
The blue letters after the red letters end
correspond to the 3' UTR. The untranslated regions often contain
information that helpsregulate translation. The black letters between the exons correspond to introns.
An intron begins witha five prime splice donor site and ends with a three prime splice acceptor site.
Remember that thefive prime splice donor site of the intron usuallyhas the sequence GT,
while the three prime splice
acceptor site has the sequence AG. When we remove
all the introns and begin reading at the first
word, the message tells us that "the fat old cat ate
the big rat." "The" is the beginning of our processed
message and represents the start codon of the open
reading frame. When you read this message, your
brain converts the message into a mental image.
Similarly, the translational machinery reads the
processed transcript and converts it into a protein.
Because an exon could end in the middle of
a word, we use the term "phase" to describe the
number of letters between the last complete word,
or codon, and the five prime splice donor site.
If the last base of the codon coincides
with the end of an exon, then we would
consider the five prime splice donor site for
that exon to be in phase zero. In this example,
the word "fat" in our message is complete before
the splice donor site. Hence, we would consider
this splice donor site to be in Phase 0. If
the splice site cuts off the codon in an exon
after one base, we would consider the five prime
splice donor site for that exon to be in Phase 1.
In this example the word "cat" is split
between two exons. The letter C is in
exon two and the letters A and T are in exon
three. If the splice site cuts off the codon in
an exon after two bases, we would consider the
five prime splice donor site for that exon to
be in Phase 2. In this example, the word "ate"
is split between two exons. The letters A and T
are in exon three and the letter E is in exon four.
Note that the phase of the five prime donor site
must be compatible with the phase of the
three prime acceptor site. The sum of the
donor and acceptor phases must either be zero,
no additional codon, or three (an additional codon).
Do remember to analyze splice junctions carefully.
Examine the splice junction between exons four and
five. There are two ways to form the words
"big rat." However, only the second option
utilizes the canonical five prime splice donor and
the three prime splice acceptor sites in intron four.